it's another election in Pakistan but
the mood is subdued in a country
recovering from its worst economic and
political crisis in decades in April
2022 prime minister Imran Khan was outed
through a vote of no confidence he
resigned from Parliament and dissolved
the provincial Assemblies of two major
provinces to PVE way for new
elections Khan is now in prison and B
from the upcoming elections but his
party of loyalists are determined
to take part as independent
candidates former prime minister Naas
Sharif was previously convicted of
corruption charges is back and has been
given relief from all previous
convictions another Contender is Bela
buo of the Pakistan People's Party son
of the assassinated former prime
minister Benazir
BTO this is rural Sint Province the
butto family stronghold for for decades
Pakistan's Southern province of s has
been ruled by dynasties and feudal Lords
they've become even more powerful and
wealthier even as the vast majority live
in abject poverty without adequate
Health Care education and even clean
drinking
water The Shining Tomb of the BTO family
stands out from the dwelling of the poor
for them it's a story of misery and
success governments have not lived up to
their campaign
promises we are disappointed from all
leaders of this country as they consider
us their slaves look at our house we
don't even have enough to feed our kids
we have seen many elections but this
time too won't make any
difference Bel B party slogan is bread
clothes and house for every poor but
Decades of rule by his party has not
brought about about change the problems
that you mentioned are not isolated to
synth poverty water scarcity are
problems that we face in sin bistan
P um not only in our country in India
which is much
uh larger than us also faces such
problems without Imran Khan in the race
the fight will remain between the
Pakistan people's party and the Muslim
League Naas years of mismanagement ramp
corruption and misuse of power has
undermined confidence in the system
people across Pakistan worry if these
elections will be free and fair and ask
whether their vote will even be counted
or ignored like previous elections Kamal
Hayer Al jazer
Islamabad make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer